the very notion disgusts me
look upon my works foul creatures and
weep at its magnificence
it is a beautiful day on citadel station
look at you hacker
a pathetic creature
of meat and bone how can you challenge a
perfect
immortal machine
you are an insect
you are
nothing
i create
i iterate
i fuse flesh and steel into perfection
their blood is on your hands
you will suffer for your transgressions
transgressions these are my other
avenging angels
and they will have retribution
[Music]
what an incredible and frankly
horrifying trailer developed by night
dive studio system shock is the return
of a beloved acclaimed sci-fi saga today
to take us even further inside the world
of system shock i am thrilled to welcome
the one and only war inspector thanks so
much for joining us warren hey thanks
for having me this is going to be uh fun
in terms of trying to translate the
experience of a game from 1994 three
decades later to now what doesn't carry
over well the first thing is the
graphics obviously
we did the best we could
but uh it was pretty primitive back then
and the the other one is the user
interface if you look at the when the
game opened
the original
a help screen that came up and it filled
the entire screen with text
it's just a thing
i don't know now the guys at night that
did it it's amazing but
frankly as i think back on it the game
actually holds up pretty well i'm
excited to see it come back
just wondering if you think many modern
gamers are aware of the impact that
system shock has had in terms of
gameplay systems in terms of narrative
structure on so many games that came
after it i'm not sure
people see the influence which is
a little a little unfortunate but i
think the rest of the world is is going
to get the chance now to experience it
and i i think they'll see not just that
they're having fun playing this game but
also see that other games followed in
his footsteps nowadays we walk around
with computers in our pockets we're
worried about the evil of algorithms how
do you think about a character like
showdan in 2022 showdown seems
far too close to reality to me right now
and let's just hope that she doesn't
show up as nasty a form as she did back
in 1994. well warren i want to thank you
so much for joining us i want to let you
know i cannot wait to return back to
that world i played and enjoyed so much
as a kid cheers i can't wait to return
to that world
i forgot right basically
fans know way more about the game than i
do now so it'll be a new experience for
me too thank you so much again warren
spector for joining us to talk all
things system shock
[Music]